[Applause]
this will not be my campaign this will
be our campaign all together
former president Donald Trump has
announced his plan to run in the 2024
presidential election after spending
months on the midterm campaign Trail
endorsing a host of Republican
candidates
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all while Trump remains
a clear leader in the Republican Party
his appeal has changed since he ran in
2016 and 2020. there's sort of fatigue
among some Republicans over Donald Trump
and his Antics and what what he's left
the party with so what has changed since
his first two presidential campaigns and
how could those changes impact his
political power and influence in the
2024 presidential election
several of the Republican midterm
candidates that Trump endorsed and
campaigned with were expected to be a
part of a so-called red wave that would
carry the party to complete control of
Congress just three days from now the
people of Pennsylvania are going to
elect Dr Mehmet Oz to the United States
Senate but the outcome of the midterms
was weaker than expected for the GOP
Republicans are poised to flip control
of the house but several trump-backed
candidates in pivotal Senate races
struggled and the party was unable to
flip control of the Senate candidates
who embraced Trump's unfounded election
fraud claims performed particularly
poorly in the midterms Blake Masters who
lost in Arizona to the Democratic
incumbent Mark Kelly aligned himself
with Trump supporting National Abortion
restrictions and claims of 2020 election
fraud he lost independent voters by more
than 30 percentage points according to
AP vote cast that and similar situations
with other trump-backed candidates like
Tudor Dixon and Doug mastriano called
into question the power of a trump
endorsement and whether his brand has
turned away some independent voters
there are people who normally would not
talk on the record talking on the record
to reporters and elsewhere about Donald
Trump needs to move on it's time for
someone else
[Music]
but one trumped-backed candidate did
perform well among voters
accomplish more than anybody thought
possible
few and I have only begun to fight Ron
desantis's midterm election victory was
so huge that it is sort of Rewritten how
Republicans are looking at the
presidential race Suddenly It's Not Just
Donald Trump's nomination to to lose
DeSantis has not announced a
presidential bid but Trump has already
started attacking the Florida governor
is Trump at 71 Rhonda sanctimonious at
ten percent DeSantis Victory comes after
some Republicans have openly called for
the party to move past the former
president and look for a new leader it's
basically the third election in a row
that Donald Trump has cost us uh the
race and it's like you know three
strikes you're out there is a growing
sense of Republicans identifying more as
members of the GOP versus supporters of
Donald Trump following the midterm
elections some Republicans have said
that Trump's influence and endorsement
choices have cost the party winnable
races those who are most closely aligned
with the former president did
underperformed those who are talking
about the future who have managed their
states well they over performed other
potential Challengers for the Republican
nomination include Trump's 2016 running
mate former vice president Mike Pence
who parted ways with Trump following the
January 6 attack on the capitol
foreign
thing will be really interesting to
watch is how not just voters but the
donors the big money people and who they
put their money behind a lot of them do
want to see someone else Trump has a
proven track record when it comes to
online and Grassroots fundraising even
after leaving the Oval Office earlier
this year a Federal Election Commission
filing showed that Trump had more than
120 million dollars in cash across his
post-presidential political operation
but with the presence of other potential
front-runners in the presidential race
like Ron DeSantis it remains to be seen
where donors will invest their money
they are looking to someone else that
can kind of bring the party a little bit
back to where where it had been more
traditional kind of conservatism Trump
also moves forward amid a host of legal
issues including civil and criminal
investigations into his company Trump
organization the January 6 probe and a
federal investigation into mishandled
classified White House Records
[Applause]
Trump Still Remains popular with
right-leaning voters and allies within
the party but he now faces new
challenges that could influence his
candidacy ahead of the presidential
election he still is the number one
loved figure in the party among the
voters the base there now there are
cracks in that but Donald Trump is still
a very very strong and powerful force in
the party and that should not be
overlooked even as there are some cracks
and Rising Stars like Ron DeSantis
[Music]